As the year 12.021 slowly comes to an end,
we present to you the 12.022
human era calendar, Eons edition.
As always,
we're adding 10.000 years to the regular
calendar to represent the human era
and include all cultures around the world,
but this year we're expanding the scope
beyond humanity
to showcase forgotten animals and plants
from all across the phanerozoic Eon
like giant armored fish scythe lizards or
giant sloths, on 12 elaborate pages.
Witness how multicellular life has
persisted for over half a billion years,
surviving asteroid impacts, volcanoes and
frozen oceans and of course pandemics.
In the end, life er... finds a way,
and we want to celebrate that.
You can get the very shiny high quality
limited edition now, until we set out and
then never again, to support what we do on
this channel, to fill the void
in your soul, or just to have
something beautiful to look at.
As every year, we also have bundles and
special calendar deals
with some of your favourite products.
Thank you so much to all of the thousands
of birds who get the calendar every year,
you enable us to create videos
and to publish them for free for everyone.
We wish you a happy year 12.022.
[Music]